I look for a minimum of a million dollar
in iida if the company has what we call
transferable value meaning if you own
let's say you know five candy stores and
all five candy stores do $200,000 a year
in profit then that would be something
that I might be interested in as long as
it's not your face that's the reason
that they're doing which most local
businesses is not the case right or if
you own an accounting firm that was
doing a million dollars a year in profit
and it's not based again on your face
then it would be something that I would
be okay with if it is a personality
brand or based on a Creator or around a
creator then the minimum line is $2
million a year in profit and again the
reason there is that there is actually
less transferable value in that business
and there's actually more work that has
to get done to remove the face of the
founder so that there is Enterprise
Value